okay what do we do next episode oh I
don't know yeah you didn't tell your
story either yeah in what my story
you started off saying that the before
we record we said that'll be gold and
now I forget what it was oh I don't know
it probably wasn't gold none of this was
gold it could be gold hello everybody my
name is markiplier and welcome back to
the forest hi Jess I'm more enthusiastic
please I was more enthusiastic before
when we came up with our plan of what
we're gonna do we have no idea what
we're doing like every episode of drunk
minecraft which we need to start off you
needed to join us on uh yeah we're gonna
build a house are we said are we still
talking about the forest okay yes
well you think we're talking about I'm
not talking about drunk minecraft I
can't run anymore I need a drink okay
huh you got some solders I do yes I need
food though only one sack and a leg a
candy bars you got candy bars I only got
one and I got a leg I can't I drop candy
bars uh I don't know how you drop
anything
Fareway we got to find a location ha ha
ha ha walking around my inventory you
just have a leg did you get that what do
you mean where I got it I got a front
end eat it eat it why would I eat it
that's okay well will you block it looks
like you're eating it just like you want
a piece of Ted here tell your tenacious
anyway let's say any time you stop being
funny time to fail miserably at this
game should we start murdering trees uh
we should find the location first and
then we should start murdering trees
okay it's all of our location yes
exactly as all things in real estate and
my struggles with LA it's all about
location
mister of moving all the time dude I'm
about to move again well you're taking a
[ __ ] nomad I will this next time I'm
moving I'm actually moving to a house
with some other dudes and we're gonna
have like a production place to go to oh
Jesus dogs killed their years wait no
that doesn't make any sense
you know what I just said never mind yes
I'm moving again further proving how
great you are it is the best commentary
10/10 Doritos Mountain Dew
ten attend commentary who are you moving
in with or is it a super duper ooper
secret no it's a sin to go guys
oh yeah you could have just said I'm
moving with the cyndago guys instead of
a bunch of dudes well I mean it's the
same description like do I need to say
anymore oh yeah I almost died oh [ __ ]
why why are you always hiding your
personal life from people Merrick I
don't know why do you keep telling
everybody about all your dirty dark
secrets huh because I am a terrible
person and they need to not be
disappointed by whoa really deep really
not realize oh my god I'm so sorry I
brought this up I didn't mean to get
this deep it I do get that way though
open like people meet us at conventions
I'm like I hope you're not disappointed
by me really yeah you say are you still
fault okay could you still follow me I'm
still following you ya know why we need
to find shelter soon or else we're gonna
die in the night ah yeah but anyway yeah
I'm gonna we're gonna be moving into a
house yeah yeah sorry to disappoint
everybody yep
I'm moving again you want to know why
rent is too high no no people found my
place Oh people been there yeah really
people have found your face oh yeah well
iers towns are very small okay and like
I keep meeting the same people when I go
out as well yeah yeah but no people show
up on my doorstep and they're like
here's some cookies can I come in ya
know yeah I mean the same thing happened
to me in that one is like a new
apartment building those in and then
everyone I met was like oh my god you're
Marga black I'm like cool alright just
don't don't find which apartment I'm in
and then listen people are coming up and
knocking on my door or ringing my
doorbell oh great we love you guys but
home is home yeah exactly like it's not
a thing that I don't wanna meet fans
it's that I when I'm in my home I don't
whoa the heck happened to the water I
didn't know moonshine yeah apparently
but yeah it's like like everyone has
personal space and like when I'm when
I'm home and cuz I'm an introvert it's
like I go home and I want to be home but
if people are talking on my
or at 8 o'clock at night like they were
it's kind of weird
yeah exactly and plus you know that one
person is gonna get the address out and
then people are gonna like send you
bombs in the mail or something out but
yeah yeah I can't have anything yeah all
I see is boom boom economy good
just follow the bum bum I have flares
but wait water you have flares wait yep
I'm fine what about maybe it'll work on
maybe a working water let me let me open
up my picnic basket here in the middle
Yosh in here it looks like there's a
loaf of bread next to your name haha
showed you I'm a flare it up as well
then yeah actually it's it's
scientifically flares are I believe
magnesium rthday or no not magnesium but
I believe flares can fire underwater
because they're not it's not an oxygen
based reaction I think yeah it's all
chemical yeah exactly
powdered yeah some way let's just
submerged in water then I don't know if
they work uh who knows maybe it's like
it creates like I forget what the name
of it is but there's that bubble of air
around hot objects if you like dunk a
super hot ball in water there'll be a
sphere of like air around it that won't
give like won't the water won't touch it
you know what I mean yeah and and it's
like it's the same effect that allows
your finger to dip in a wet finger to
dip into a tub of molten lead and not
get oh yeah you saw that that's cool I
forget what the name of the effect is
like the bisque off the fact or
something like that
wait no bisque off is a cookie never
mind that's totally normal super
scientific supercooled liquids and
bubbles of heat around it's like I think
it's called bisque off cookies exactly
margov liars advice uh eat cookies and
dip your finger in lead and molten lead
molten led of course you go way ahead of
me how'd you swim so fast I shift swam i
sprint swim oh is it just me or do trees
not cut down anymore they do you should
have whack them extra hard what they
used to like you know look like they're
being cut down fragment
I don't know I don't know look I'm
trying my best and this this this ain't
whoa don't get in the way of my axe you
almost got killed
okay let's let's smack this tree
together uh-huh uh-uh
wait I need drink you're not smokey
I need to restore energy actually I'm
gonna drink some booze because I
probably need to all right
what Wow what Rhys app collected yeah I
don't know what that's all about
did they like change it where this axe
doesn't cut down trees anymore I don't
oh god damn it okay how about I combine
a stick with no a combine a stick with a
rock and the tree sap wherever that went
with my work I don't think you know how
physics works I don't think we know how
physics what's romantic I don't know
anything
yeah oh wait no that's all I need I
don't need any lashing axe rapid no fine
trees how do i how do i why do I forget
how to play how do I once I put things
in the middle how do I like do the thing
it's should there we go I got it okay
it's like a little cog I got it okay so
now I have a stone axe is this working
now is it working yeah it's working it's
not working okay never mind how do I
like this how do you like what whoa hell
and make fire I make fire keep far away
from my face oh come here
excuse me please you're getting all
right my personal space yes
no exit burn no you're so [ __ ] crispy
it just it just makes you me uh look
longingly into your eyes as we yeah yeah
share this on what oh let it go I said
let's get it on oh I saw you said let it
go like how in the world does frozen
apply in this situation no oh god open
up your inventory but this equipped why
how can I only quit this hmm good max
why y'all no frickin way to cut down
trees any
or yeah help what the hell happened with
this game used to be cool game you
changed I don't know maybe we're just
stupid I mean I don't want to call it
out as a possibility but just maybe just
maybe we're dumb I'm bettin heavy hunt
that's it
all right hang on uh-huh [ __ ] you Bush
frickin my god this is some like wow I
know I see a mountain in the distance
you do where a matter of Warren damn I'm
super hungry I have like no food I'm not
okay uh-huh
I'd give you candy bars if I could well
that's okay I've got like no we can get
seeds to grow a thing I'm like frostbite
here I've got ice around my edges can
you help please
how am I suppose the hell no build me a
fire I'm like the wife in this
relationship you need to talk to me I
can deal with that okay mine bill file
man build fire but maybe man could build
fire if he didn't go out drinking so
much
ha ha ha ha I keep putting nut every
time I tried to put on the fire nothing
happens why i press e to put down fire
vanishes um me thinks we're stupid
he thinks the server is not working
methinks you might be right
methinks me server not communicates so
well with me CH other each other there
may have been an issue well man
the mushrooms that's a good idea Oh
mushrooms can I hear at my feet I got
him
easy fall now I don't know they don't
seem to be making me go crazy so I'm
pretty sure it's ok yeah ok then you eat
the mushrooms with your blood on it whoa
why I don't know you gotta kill me is a
crazy kid at ages ago who turned into a
meme what never see the sushi blood kid
guy no they could Dyna eat the sushi
with my blood on it
no he's one of they like kids reacts or
teens react no oh
oh good good for him I guess yeah okay
should we go towards mountain or is the
game gonna say area not accessible they
opened up the area a bit more to in one
of the many updates that happened which
apparently changed the game so much that
we forgot how to play hard explorers
yeah exactly
since we can't build a shelter will be
permanent nomads nomads no dad no bad no
bad races I don't think we forgot how to
play it it's just not working how do you
forget how to chop down a tree yeah I
guess you're right be right so maybe
it's just cuz I'm hosting it and that's
stupid yeah yeah he's a whole stupid
aura around you well that's pretty mean
dude hey is that is that the cockpit
yeah I thought it was like a shark head
or something you did it'd be a big I
sure kid but isn't that like a big thing
in the game we're supposed to find like
the cockpit oh go man go oh I will go if
I could get a torch to go in maybe
builds one I'm building one wait yeah
there we go okay how do they plan so
perfectly in a little island how do i
light it L and then swing that's what I
did
Elms L takes out your lighter and then
swing kind of seems to light it i nope
didn't work I'll just go in with the
lighter all right cool hi-yah huh so
anything in here
well there's dentist this guy's like
really dead like zoo flare gun
flare gun where and computer chipboards
oh dude you were not wearing your seat
belt oh yeah that guy doesn't seem so
good I mean he's the one who caused the
damage probably you give him
mouth-to-mouth and I'll equip the flare
gun
I'll give him mouth to ass well that's
one option
holy butthole butthole that was a story
the pig buttholes
that was it yeah that was it oh thank
you for reminding me by making out with
that guy's anus he was talking about pig
butt holes before he requires like no
save this for the video this is YouTube
gold all I was saying is that
you can buy pickled buttholes in bulk
and the reason why that's the story
there we go congratulations everybody
know the reason why is because you can
you can buy pig intestines to make
sausage because that's what sausage is
usually in but when they trim the end
it's literally like the end of the
intestine is the anus so they have a lot
of a nooses leftover so you can buy pig
buttholes in bulk you're proud of me mom
that's the end of the episodes thank you
everybody so much for watching oh boy
quite a living you're making there son
my mom is so proud and my mom is
probably watching this hi mom hi mom
bye mom see you next and everybody
swinging and missing at you
oh my god that's so cool that's so cool
it's so cool